trauer um ruth bader ginsburg nach dem
tod der liberalen richterin am obersten
us-gericht ist ein erbitterter streit
über ihre nachfolge entbrannt
weite wiesen münchen auf der schwierigen
suche nach einem oktoberfest in corona
format und radeln für reformen
bundesweit wird für eine wende in der
verkehrspolitik in die pedale getreten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg den abend und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
samstag norbert lehmann ist auch dabei
für den sportlicher relevanter familie
bader ginsberg war eine brillante
juristin und eine ikone der
frauenbewegung in den usa aber nicht nur
deshalb löst der tod der 87-jährigen
heftige reaktionen aus die frage wer der
verfassungsrichterin nachfolgt spielt
mitten im wahlkampf eine entscheidende
rolle
27 jahre lang arbeitete ginsburg am
supreme court dieses höchste gericht der
vereinigten staaten hat mit ihr ein
weiteres links liberales mitglied
verloren 5 der aktuell acht richter
gelten als konservativ drei als liberal
die neubesetzung der neunten stelle ist
ein politischer kampf der supreme court
hat gewaltige macht auf das letzte wort
bei wegweisenden entscheidungen
die richter werden ernannt auf
lebenszeit vom präsidenten aus
washington jutta sonne wald bis zuletzt
hat newspaper ginsburg gekämpft gegen
ihre krebserkrankung und für die rechte
von frauen und minderheiten landesweit
berühmt und beliebt wurde die
amerikanische oberste
verfassungsrichterin
durch ihre entschlossenheit ihrer
scharfsinnige argumentation und ihre
liebe zum beruf
es ist erstaunlich so viele menschen
wollen ein foto mit mir machen es gibt
sogar tattoos mit meinem namen und
meinem gesicht
ginsburg hat sich aus einer einfachen
jüdischen einwanderer familie
hochgekämpft 1993 nominierte sie
präsident bill clinton für den obersten
gerichtshof der usa als zweite frau
überhaupt an diesem gericht als liberale
juristin hat sie sich gegen die
todesstrafe eingesetzt für
gleichgeschlechtliche ehe und das recht
auf abtreibung
es ist eine traurige wahrheit dass jeder
versucht das recht auf abtreibung
einzuschränken die ärmsten der
bevölkerung trifft wenn auch ideologisch
nicht auf derselben linie
so würdigte auch der us-präsident
ginsburg als eine titanen des rechts
ob man ihrer meinung war oder nicht sie
war eine erstaunliche form mit einem
erstaunlichen leben
der präsident wird aber auch dass er
sich verpflichtet fühle den posten ohne
verzug neu zu besetzen
damit wollen die republikaner ihre
konservative mehrheit am supreme court
weiter zementieren
das oberste gericht ist mehr als eine
juristische kontrollinstanz viele
streitthemen die im us-kongress nicht
gelöst werden können landen hier so
machen die neuen richter die auf
lebenszeit ernannt werden hier de facto
direkt politik daher wollen die
demokraten die nachfolge erst nach der
wahl regeln die wähler sollten erst im
präsidenten bestimmen der präsident soll
einen richter vorschlag machen über den
der senat dann bestimmen kann
amerika trauert um lose battle ginsburg
um ihre nachfolge am obersten gericht
ist ein erbitterter politischer
richtungskampf entbrannt ines trams
steht jetzt vor dem supreme court in
washington ines wird es dem präsidenten
gelingen den platz von regensburg noch
vor der wahl neu zu besetzen
zumindest will präsident tom danach
sieht es im moment aus genau das
versuchen in einem kraftakt will er den
freien richter sessel bis zur wahl neu
besetzen unklar aber ob das gelingt die
demokraten werden das ganz klar
bekämpfen und es ist auch nicht gegeben
dass die republikaner im senat
da jeweils mitgehen werden denn es gibt
ja die tradition das so wichtige
richterposten so kurz vor einer
präsidentschaftswahl dann eben doch
nicht mehr neu besetzt werden sollen
aber alleine die aussicht auf eine
konservative mehrheit am supreme court
die wird allein schon den wahlkampf
dramatisch beeinflussen ich denke zum
nachteil von joe biden tram wird weiter
noch als bisher versuchen den wahlkampf
zu einem kultur kampf um die ausrichtung
amerikas auszubauen er wird versuchen
konservative und religiöse evangelikale
wähler mit diesem thema zu mobilisieren
ich denke also dieser freie richter
sessel ist die schärfste waffe die sich
jump für den verbleibenden wahl kommt
nur wünschen konnte live aus washington
ist ramms vielen dank für diese
einschätzung
in der zdf mediathek finden sie eine
dokumentation über das wirken der us
richterin mit dem titel jeff bader
ginsburg ein leben für die gerechtigkeit
auch abrufbar in unserer zdf heute app
zur corona lage da steigen die zahlen
bei uns in deutschland weiter an das
robert koch institut meldet 2297 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages ein
neuer höchstwert seit april im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich laut johns hopkins
universität 1640 menschen jeden tag neu
angesteckt
trotz des neuen höchstwert zeigt sich
gesundheitsminister sparen gelassen
aktuell könne unser gesundheitssystem
gut mit der situation umgehen er rief
aber erneut zur vorsicht auf das gilt
auch für münchen dort wurde gestern der
kritische wert von 50 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohnern überschritten
heute hätte dort eigentlich das
oktoberfest begonnen
das ist zwar längst abgesagt trotzdem
scheint die lust zum feiern groß auch
aus sorge vor einer wilden wiesen
verhängte die stadt an vielen plätzen
ein alkoholverbot claudia vogel man das
hat die bavaria noch nicht erlebt in
ihrem schatten wollen einige die absage
des oktoberfestes nicht hinnehmen und
feiern auch die ihre art und ihrem
schutz suchen aber auch 500 menschen in
der mobilen corona teststation
gewissheit ob sie sich angesteckt haben
oder nicht alkoholverbot auf der wiesn
und trotzdem sind ein paar menschen
gekommen um zu feiern
über 50 wird er in der münchner
innenstadt bieten eine alternative die
wirtshaus wesen unter mit vene aufladen
im einer am platzl stich der sprecher
der wiesnwirte das pass an dass die
leute natürlich wenn sie aufstehen den
mundschutz tragen und das haben wir
bewiesen dass wir das können bis zum
vierten oktober soll die wiesn stimmung
in der münchner wirtshäusern gefeiert
werden die virologin warnt wenn ich im
wirtshaus sitze und ich kann die fenster
nicht aufmachen und dann ist vielleicht
noch alkohol im spiel und man vergisst
einfach auch dass man ein bisschen den
abstand einhalten sollte ist dann eine
reelle gefahr dar
münchen liegt bei der höhe der
infektionszahlen mittlerweile weit vorne
dennoch wird auf der wirtshaus wiesen
ausgelassen gefeiert
[Musik]
ich meine sich zu verstecken ist ja auch
keine alternative gesundheit bei vollem
genuss ist machbar demonstrieren diese
wiesen profis der mundschutz war ich nur
kurz für einen schluck bier an wandel in
zeiten von corona mit bündeln vor und
hinter glas auch das ist münchen am tag
des abgesagten oktoberfest anstiegs
unsere nachbarn kämpfen mit noch viel
deutlicher ansteigenden corona zahlen
österreich meldete zuletzt etwa 800
neuinfektionen pro tag dabei hat das
land nur etwa ein zehntel der einwohner
von deutschland in frankreich erreichen
die neuinfektionen mit mehr als 13.000
100 einen neuen höchststand
und auch in spanien steigen die zahlen
besorgniserregend an auf inzwischen fast
1000 14.400 an einem tag ein drittel
davon im großraum madrid an arendt
berichtet sie leben dicht an dicht in
puente der bikers einem der arbeiter
bezirke im süden madrids hier wie in
sechs weiteren stadtteilen breitet sich
das virus rasant aus ab montag dürfen
die bewohner nur noch in dringenden
fällen ihre viertel verlassen um zur
arbeit oder zum arzt zu gehen
wozu soll das gut sein ein viertel
abzusperren und die straße ist dann die
grenze
am ende sitzen wir doch alle zusammen in
den bussen und u bahnen
ich glaube die maßnahmen werden nichts
bringen
denn wenn es nicht mehr ärzte
krankenschwestern und trailer gibt wird
sich das virus weiter ausbreiten
die region madrid steht bei der pandemie
bekämpfung massiv in der kritik
zu wenig tests zu wenig personal die
sorge ist groß dass das
gesundheitssystem schon bald kollabiert
lange hat sich die konservative
regionalregierung gegen jegliche
einmischung der linken zentralregierung
gewährt nun bittet sie um hilfe
wir brauchen die unterstützung der
regierung wenn wir zusammenarbeiten
werden wir das in den griff bekommen
wir müssen den kompletten lockdown auf
jeden fall vermeiden
wir müssen die wirtschaftliche
katastrophe vermeiden
ökonomie in den arbeitervierteln ist man
ratlos wie das gelingen soll
wie können den virus kaum entkommen und
leiden wie schon im frühjahr besonders
unter dem missmanagement der politik in
der korona krise belarus kommt nicht zur
ruhe in minsk at polizei hunderte
menschen bei demonstrationen
festgenommen wie hier in der hauptstadt
haben sich frauen im ganzen land wieder
zu friedlichen protesten gegen
staatschef lukaschenko versammelt
trotzdem gehen die polizisten hart gegen
die frauen vor und nehmen viele fest die
bewegung fordert neuwahlen die
freilassung aller politischen gefangenen
und die strafrechtliche verfolgung von
polizeigewalt
so wird nach deutschland die fdp hatte
schon bessere zeiten ihre umfragewerte
sind nicht berauschend die art wie
generalsekretären teuteberg abgelöst
wurde fanden vor allem frauen nicht gut
der parteitag heute der erste nicht
digitale in corona zeiten sollte nun ein
signal zum aufbruch werden um nach der
bundestagswahl in einem jahr wieder
mitzuregieren
da ist auch der neue generalsekretär
gefragt aus berlin frank buchwald
leicht wird das nicht volker wissing
muss kämpfen in umfragen kratzt die fdp
hart an der fünf-prozent-hürde
als opposition sucht sie im bundestag
doch immer ihr zentrales thema wissing
setzt nun auf alte stärken
wirtschaftskompetenz
wir brauchen eine finanz und
steuerpolitik die mehr private
investitionen ermöglicht den forschungen
entwicklung damit klimaschutz und
nachhaltigkeit erreicht werden können
ohne dass sich soziale fragen in unserer
gesellschaft geben
der neue generalsekretär steht aber auch
für eine neue richtung
er gilt als architekt einer koalition
mit spd und grünen die fdp lösen vermag
sie sei ein ewiges anhängsel der union
ich halte sehr viel von volker wissing
finde er sehr gute rede gehalten gerade
steht ein für die soziale
marktwirtschaft für die
entscheidungsfreiheit des einzelnen aber
auch jemand der betont dass man den
einzelnen aber nicht alleine lassen darf
die liberalen wollen regieren
daran lässt auch parteichef lindner
keinen zweifel seine botschaft für das
superwahljahr 2021 eindeutig ich möchte
dass wir uns das ziel setzen dass im
nächsten jahr die freien demokraten
gebraucht werden um eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag zu bilden
wir müssen so stark wieder werden dass
wir mit entscheiden können über die
richtung die dieses land nimmt er tritt
dann jedoch nicht mehr an da man otto
solms wird in ein paar wochen 80 zieht
sich nach jahrzehnten aus der
parteiführung zurück die delegierten
dankten ihm mit langem applaus und
wählten ihn zum ehrenvorsitzenden
die fdp will wieder regieren ralf
schumacher was bietet sie den wählen der
die fdp will eine kehrtwende in der
wirtschaftspolitik staatlichen einfluss
zurückdrängen mehr marktwirtschaft
niedrige steuern heißt dass
bürokratieabbau bessere digitale
infrastruktur klassische fdp-forderungen
die jetzt für ein neues
wirtschaftswunder sorgen sollen ein
großes versprechen in corona zeiten
parteichef lindner und der neue
generalsekretär wissing positionieren
die liberalen als retter in der
wirtschaftskrise
die partei hofft aber zuallererst auf
ein ende der eigenen krise raus aus dem
umfragetief die selbstgewählte
oppositionsrolle hat selbst stammwähler
wenig begeistert und zurück in die
regierung das ist die botschaft
ob die fdp dafür überhaupt gebraucht
wird entscheidet sich ziehen
genau in einem jahr will für diese
einschätzung von fdp parteitag aus
berlin ralf schumacher rechtsextreme
gruppen von polizisten in nordrhein
westfalen haben diese woche schlagzeilen
gemacht jetzt wurde ähnliches aus
mecklenburg-vorpommern bekannt gegen 18
beamte laufen ermittlungen zwei wurden
bereits vom dienst suspendiert sie
sollen auf ihre privathandys
antisemitische und nazi verherrlichenden
nachrichten verschickt haben
der blumenhändler enver simsek war das
erste mordopfer der rechtsextremen
terrorzelle nsu die stadt jena hat heute
einen platz nach ihm benannt
hier im stadtteil winzerla hatten sich
die haupttäter des sogenannten
nationalsozialistischen untergrunds in
den 90er jahren radikalisiert sie
ermordeten insgesamt zehn menschen
thüringens ministerpräsident ramelow
forderte eine kultur in der man nicht
schweigt und nicht wegschaut
es sind beunruhigende zahlen alle 19
minuten wird in deutschland ein kind im
straßenverkehr verletzt im vergangenen
jahr starben 55 kinder bei unfällen
das sind zwar deutlich weniger als in
den jahren zuvor trotzdem deutsche
innenstädte müssen kinder und vor allem
fahrradfreundlicher werden forderten
heute tausende radler im ganzen land
dorothea dörner und klaas berichten
aufbruch zur fahrer die mobile familie
marienthal in freiburg obwohl die stadt
bei fahrradfahrern im bundesweiten
vergleich relativ gut weg kommt in ihrem
alltag mit rad sehen eltern und kinder
noch viel platz für verbesserungen
und wenn man irgendwie in meinem alter
ist und wittern kommt man da alleine
darüber aber mit vielen kindern schafft
man das halt nicht
die veranstalter der bundesweiten demos
kritisieren dass die bedingungen für
radfahrende vielerorts schlecht sein
insbesondere für kinder und jugendliche
es gibt einfach zu wenige radwege zu
schmale die sind schlecht in stand
gehalten
und die sind auch nicht geschützt vor
dem autoverkehr zum beispiel durch eine
bauliche trennung im das vermissen wir
und dass es auch eine unserer zentralen
forderungen bei den städten und
gemeinden verweist man darauf dass in
den vergangenen jahren schon einiges
getan worden sei etwa beim ausbau von
radwegen und fahrradabstellplätzen sieht
aber auch mancherorts noch nachholbedarf
wir brauchen vor allen dingen dort wo
noch nicht so viel gemacht wird
vielerorts noch einen mentalitätswechsel
wir haben ja seit jahren das leitbild
der autogerechten stadt in vielen
kommunen verfolgt und davon müssen wir
weg ein ziel das vor ort in politik und
bevölkerung aber auch widerstände
auslöst in freiburg setzt die stadt auf
dialog und verspricht nach lösungen für
die stellen zu suchen an denen
radfahrende probleme sehen
zum fussball norbert da gab es heute
nicht die bundesliga sondern auch einen
auftritt der nationalmannschaft und die
hat ihre erfolgsserie in der em
qualifikation
trotz langer corona zwangspause
fortgesetzt die dfb auswahl bezwang beim
riester hat den essen irland souverän
mit 3 0
fünftes spiel fünfter sieg und
tabellenführung 34 zu null das
torverhältnis selbstbewusst blickt die
mannschaft daher auf die em in zwei
jahren in england wir wollen wieder oben
an knöpfen wir wollen auch dann wenn
zwei jahren europameister werden
das frühe 1 0 gegen irland köpft nach
sieben minuten marina hegering auf
vorlage von marian dann scheidet julia
gewinnen mit einer knieverletzung aus
wie wird noch im krankenhaus untersucht
spielmacherin dzsenifer marozsán von
champions league sieger olympique lyon
mit einer starken leistung und dem
herrlichen treffer zum 2 0
noch in der ersten halbzeit gelingt
lehrer schüler das drei zu null
die qualifikation für die
europameisterschaft ist damit nur noch
eine formsache
und unsere fußball bundesliga alle
spiele heute mit publikum nur in köln
nicht der fc verlor gegen hoffenheim mit
2 3
hier die bisherigen ergebnisse des
ersten spieltags frankfurt bielefeld
eins zu eins union berlin augsburg 1 zu
3 bremen härte eins zu vier
stuttgart freiburg 2 zu 3 das abendspiel
dortmund gegen gladbach bereits gestern
deklassierte bayern schalke mit 8 zu 0
morgen an leipzig gegen meister
wolfsburg gegen leverkusen die tabelle
am ersten spieltag ja noch wenig
aussagekräftig die bayern sind erster
und haben mit den sieg gegen schalke ein
dickes ausrufezeichen gesetzt dahinter
dann härter augsburg freiburg und
hoffenheim am tabellenende der finden
sich union werder und schalke wieder
alle spiele alle tore und natürlich
ausführlich das abendspiel dortmund
gegen gladbach im aktuellen sportstudio
mit dunja hayali um 23 uhr 30
vorentscheidung bei der tour de france
sa depot katar hat überraschend das
gelbe trikot erobert beim bergzeitfahren
gewinnt er mit großem vorsprung und
primus roger minute 56 sekunden und
damit das gelbe trikot ab programm steht
damit vor dem tour sieg der tradition
folgend wird auf der letzten etappe
morgen nach paris nicht mehr
eingegriffen
überraschung bei der beachvolleyball em
in lettland kim behrens und cinja
tillmann haben das halbfinale erreicht
sie gewannen gegen die russinnen
swetlana pollina und nadeshda marokko
server mit 2 0 sätzen
das duo aus münster war als ersatzteam
in den deutschen em kader kümmern nach
gebunden
und beim atp tennis turnier in rom ist
dominik koepfer im viertelfinale gegen
den weltranglisten ersten novak djokovic
ausgeschieden
nach großem kampf nicht der
schwarzwälder in roth im zweiten satz
gegen den weltranglisten ersten aus
musste sich dann aber im entscheidenden
dritten satz geschlagen
der serbe gewann mit 64 zu 61 63 meinen
job meldung nach der anderen vielen dank
morgen erwartet uns ein spätsommer
sonntag mit viel sonne und höchstens an
den alpen mal einem schauer
wie lange das noch so bleibt hören wir
gleich von katharina das heute journal
gegen viertel nach elf mit marietta
slomka
wir danken ihnen für ihr interesse
wünschen einen unbeschwerten
samstagabend und sagen tschüss bis
morgen wenn sie mögen mir wären wieder
da
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
technologisch sind wir deutschlandweit
schon im vollherbst angekommen der ist
nämlich dann erreicht wenn die eicheln
zu boden fallen aber gefühlt ist das ja
draußen wirklich noch spätsommer auch
wenn sich nebelfelder mal länger halten
können wie dieses niebel fällt hier
südlich der donau
da dauerte es bis zum frühen nachmittag
bis es sich auflöste über den nordosten
zogen hochnebelfelder und von frankreich
zogen einige dichtere wolken hier in den
südwesten und diese dichteren wolken
breiten sich auch in der nacht weiter
richtung dort meist aber es ist klar
dass besitz sich neuer nebel und es wird
wieder sehr kühl
die temperaturen sinken meist auf 7 bis
4 grad ganz ausgeschlossen ist der
bodenfrost nicht milder bleibt die nacht
an der küste und auch im südwest bei 8
bis 13 grad und morgen erwarten uns dann
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 20 grad im
westerzgebirge und 24 grad an der elbe
an rhein und westlich davon wird es
sommerlich warm mit 25 bis 27 grad
dazu scheint häufig die sonne und erst
am nachmittag entwickeln sich im
schwarzwald oder auch aus den alpen
heraus einzelne kleine regenschauer und
gewitter und an diesem wetter ändert
sich auch montag und dienstag noch wenig
aber zur wochenmitte da wird es dann vom
besten deutlich wechselhafter dann auch
kühler und regnerischer schönes
wochenende